[Applause]
how's it going around
welcome it's the last Monday melee of
the year the year end Monday melee so we
dressed up 2015 for those of you
watching in the future there were those
of you with head injuries we're here
with our G baseball signs
I'll do baseball signs okay all right
we're back welcome to the last Monday
we're here with Argentine man from Kodak
oh hey everybody Merry Christmas
okay that's enough Happy Hanukkah I was
either going up nope hanukkah's not a
thing I don't believe in it and we are
wearing our holiday sweaters today from
tipsy elves thank you tipsy elves you
can get them at tipsy elves now mom
this is like the Midwest mother version
I think it is a woman's sweater this is
I think then you're also what let's sit
up here so you people can see what it
says there birthday boy that's right
because get it if you that's Jesus all
right everybody I'm the chatroom bat
barosky over the corner creeper Jason
O'Malley
hey that is his holiday greeting that's
his jovial as he gets crazy Bunch woman
says Beth is not wearing any Christmas
wear that's true but she did eat a lot
of tinsel before we started so on the
inside she's holiday that's right you
should see a doctor that says poisonous
all right so because the last Monday of
the year we're gonna play every game we
played for clueless gamer this year how
many is that that's five and we're gonna
start with Mortal Kombat X I'm gonna
play this game or fourth except bring
Romans Mortal Kombat 10 so you pick your
guy yeah yeah and then outlast world
combat I ever played was on n64 okay and
I think there's a cheat code or maybe it
was a different to know where he is
there yeah this is a really interesting
is they're running tanya's they're
really interesting because there's a
good cold stone yashio Sonya and she
her shirt off that was the code and when
I was young it's right that was the only
action I ever got somebody said we only
watch the stream to see what Beth is
wearing and it's the same thing every
week that's right I recognize this guys
that's right that's right that's right
we're open Conan comes in later but you
know he probably won't come in a fight
what's after storms Thunder God so these
are all different variations it won't
matter to you because you're not good at
this but it kind of it depended do
different weapon master storms cuz I
love the weather that's right
a shady loves the banter between us
shady did you see I slapped him in the
face right before we started that was
awesome that was your holiday gift a
bunch of horseshit worship Tonya is a
secret stripper character captain closer
says no but seriously you do a code when
she like flash the screen and her weird
picture says he's just gonna stare at
Beth and try to figure out she's a
magical / she's not magical so psychotic
rage loving the sweaters we had a great
weekend how was your weekend RJ oh it
was good all right what's a Las Vegas oh
that's right you a fight oh my god just
similar to this game yeah very similar
Conor McGregor by the way love that oh
my god so it was like I don't know how
you do anything here I'm not moving
oh wow that's a kick how do I punch oh I
don't really know how I can't here's
here's something about clueless gamer I
only really learn how to do I only kind
of really learn how to do Cruz gamer
play the game and then I forget how to
play completely
oh whoa what was that ever a shit-ton of
I know Irish folks oh yeah they travel
and never going insane it was awesome
there were like mobs of people with the
Irish flags and stuff after that guy
make it I go like how did I got Kenny 13
seconds yeah yeah artists retell it is
that he eats an ant and then vomits on
people that doesn't make any sense
already after chug well it did it did it
does because I talked about that one
time how I ate a man oh that's right oh
my god they remembered call back people
listen to you I don't know why they
don't oh oh I'm super new UFC super
headbutt oh that's gonna leave a mark
oh yeah you can do that to me you do
both triggers do both triggers that's
just rude dude I did it again Nic Cage
that's a new one he's as crazy as Nick
Cage I don't know look at your hats all
glowed up oh oh my jumped over it
[ __ ] sweaters on freely but how do I do
this sweet oh whoa hey I didn't tell you
without even doing anything
oh I pulled your head to your stomach
awesome
that's hope he says something say
something say something
that's right to be gaming we're words
thank you know Bradley Cooper
Oh captain quasar said Beth notice me
Brad coupe for the win flamed make
another lady Brad Bradley Bradley Cooper
every time
Bradley Cooper that's Perdiccas known it
was selected page a la Bradley Cooper
oh my god she's not she's not into it
we're from the same place she's in the
Nick oh yeah here we go higher she's old
he's aged a law saying that nobody hatin
cares about I'm so I went I lived right
next to her grade school
jail I'm sure you're listening that is a
little the saddest thing I've ever heard
I lived next to her grade school what is
wrong with you
alright here we shady fridge always
thinks I look like Bradley Cooper she's
always always wrong it's a guy from the
elbe what would be arrow guy who arrow
guy a nice guy
ancestral close-up shaolin it is the
predator yeah you can't be that can you
be further I don't think we've unlocked
him Sonja you I mean I got a big
devilish web gets York over eg hash of
forces I'm gonna be demolition character
quits Isis RJ wasn't a lot within a
hundred yards of the grade school that's
true that's true
burn we're going to Outworld market ways
now here's the other thing if there's
sometimes stuff will flash in the
background okay and you can hit r1 and
you'll play grab it throw it that makes
all right with the button to bumper
trigger weights you can grab it and
throw it okay alright rifle bolt like so
we're gonna play some Liu Kang oh we're
on tattoo it's not tattoo
wait oh I've got a staff that's also a
bow
RJ for the next bar lay for the next cue
I'm into that movie yeah I'd be the next
Moneypenny
just hit me in the balls a bunch of time
combinations whoa seriously oh who are
you run Who am I I'm the guy's what is
that
I threw the old woman at you button yeah
r1 oh damn notching a my magician I feel
like I'm like a Native American magician
no you look like the guy who's like oh
yeah the bad guy the hot the priest guy
the guy who pulls everybody's parts oh
yeah dude you can do your double trigger
do your have my finger I don't know well
that's like your special move can you
get close
why did I just grab your knife like go I
don't know just hitting the boob in my
stack damn girls got some kids on her
oh he's hitting the babymaker now I'm
just gonna be sterile right I'll
brighten the dick oh yeah oh my god that
was ridiculous Adam oh Jesus I just
gotta keep my deal how do i do my power
play it's got it your your chart if they
have to be all charged up I swear to God
charge up oh yeah I mean need to charge
it by hitting me for doing good
Oh have some app how you like them
apples
get it they're apples I got a little
arrows my charge let's get her get her
oh that's the one I like the best
okay great this is likely my big sister
we were kids lots of leg sweeps yeah
exactly
I'm gonna do it now I do a 20 minute and
such a fan starts raining there's a
youtube request for the Last of Us for
next year
oh man love The Last of Us I do i wet I
don't know it is it's a game about
selecting fighter it's a game about it
just like me if I talk to you about
zombies oh you'll love this cuz you like
nature [ __ ] cordyceps you know cordyceps
is no cordyceps is no importa subsidy no
more nice EPS who errand hey who's
cordyceps cordyceps is a fungus that
gets in ants and it affects their brain
it takes their brain over and makes them
crawl up really high to a high branch
and then their head explodes
oh so it's cordyceps as the guy who's
like get over here is he on here yeah
yeah scorpion where is he he's yellow
right there
but so it's like cordyceps jumps to
humans and so all these go jump stick
you're a demon from hell I think you'll
be fine
I am yeah a jump to humans so then if
that's not what creates the zombies so
you're trying to another country and the
zombie infested it's awesome it's great
it's like a movie
Cody the dragon dude that's going to be
in the what the fact chart for which
yeah get some flexible kick up in her
became yeah oh here you want to do that
get over here yeah you've ever had to do
I think it's back back back back back
punch it might be
Wow oh sweet on it my uppercut why do I
choose costumes she says that while he's
wearing this sweater
Oh gotcha
here we go he looks like Bucky hahahaha
oh oh dude I Jeff cave your ass magic
bullet I thought that a tree sweet
that [ __ ] one I haven't heard no oh
thank you thank you
you guys should add DJ Kelly dad
snapchat it's the best thing ever
magic bullet video like I'll watch new
Star Wars but since it's Disney now I'm
not sure if it's canon it's yes it's
canon we always charge darling wait
what's the thing about Jar Jar and being
a sim what's the deal with that I think
there's a theory that they were planning
on here turns out he's barking these
guys just talk it out you know you
should do is to hit both triggers whoa
oh that's a that's sweet oh Jesus like
oh my god alright what was the name of
the superhero more compact super here
Mortal Kombat yeah oh yes that was
awesome because they had moves like this
too that Superman was like fly you out
of the world
Oh Oh No oh good
it was something all right I think it's
hot I think it's over
jeez I think it's time for us to switch
to our next game now that I start with
man you know it's all right one more
match well no no no no more medicine
yeah one more match match if you want to
lose you want to lose Brock now that
I've got the rocking and then lose bra
it's like new fire it's like new fighter
unless you want a course to play
scorpion again I'm gonna play somebody
say blue can gonna play Lu Kang is there
a subzero guy in this one you want Lu
Kang you got Luke a dead no Grandmaster
cryo man sir there's not a thing
HP per City chiropractors gold monk can
we go to my house all right
I don't know you mean your house your
place you a hold on I think it's your I
think this is you Deadwood's
because it's like the I think this is U
coz i sub-zero just the cold version of
scorpion dude it's a whole mythology
once your Wikipedia put some money on it
ooh let's put some money on it on what
this game is that this match all right
how much $100 dollars in uh a dollar one
dollar I don't have any money on us Oh
coffee coffee since I have one dollar a
coffee wait don't go yet gotta be ready
for ever
do i oh it's got something fire versus
ice
I'm just owning you oh my god can't wait
to taste that coffee I'm gonna get for
free
later gotcha
yummy I can do double trigger things
good one
that's my double trigger well done are
you kidding me I think I did
got some kicks that boy my god how come
I hit you a thousand times maybe twice
yeah I know what did you support jumping
I will
Jeep may as you kick you 50 more times
yeah yeah how come I can't shoot [ __ ]
like an old game Oh God
I don't know I think you still can use
don't know how to do it every time
yes still alive somehow oh hey I hate
you only move I know which is good noise
great you don't deserve a fit what's the
next game whoa ma'am I'll be bloody to
your face yeah I just pick my nose yeah
it's got a booger alright next name is
gonna be Tony Hawk pro skater 5 there we
go
why would change in the game I gotta see
something this year you guys sent me a
bunch of cool stuff some t-shirts which
I weren't also the newest thing I got by
the way if you want to send me stuff to
wear on the on the old streamer ooh
go for it I'm a medium t-shirt here we
go Chewbacca's dad sent me these gloves
what soo bahk is that is that just like
dads a person the chat Oh send me these
gloves cuz my hands my palms sweat so
much when I play so I got the Alize dope
gloves look at these things do you think
I even got like little little things
like like guys yeah Oh Chris Thomas said
you owe us three pieces of clothing
Aaron what here we're playing strip
Mortal Kombat Cara Lee I mean I know
I'll do three buttons yeah wait a second
I do know their every other I know we'll
see we'll see how I do it I also the
gloves came with this which I'm not sure
what this is your hands like this
wait the sweat make any sense I thought
it was a pillowcase and then I saw the
other side it's the world's smallest
pillowcase with openings at either end
sorry we all don't have a giant pillows
exactly
sorry Trump we're through spiced rum oh
my god these gloves are already heating
up my hands lobster oh this is a good
look for you
lobster scarf it's not it's it's so my
jacket is a scarf
exactly oh there's two pockets dad yep
now the games can begin that's right now
the games can begin I like these little
soft pad it has little soft pads and
there you see that I feel like this is
good for gaming also it's got my fingers
hello
you're like an old lady for Tony Hawk
hello the Tony Hawk freeze on us Oh Tony
Hawk Tony there we go we're back oh my
god all right oh this is gonna be a
rough rough little Tony Hawk experience
oh boy well it is real glitchy oh by the
way that's not exploit that's not that's
just how it looks all right I'm not sure
how this is gonna work you look how do
you play this amazing I don't know flame
pika do any of you a PlayStation Vita no
but I'd like to get one what is a
PlayStation Vita
it's like a gameboy you prefer
PlayStation Oh Tony you break in my
heart yeah we broke this game pretty
hard can someone tell me how to play
this game ah dude no I mean like what's
the point you just skate around that's
the point what's the point of any game -
oh nice one we live like one of life and
to kill you and this one is also to kill
each other
give superpowers oh my god Tony you're
killing me Tony
here we go play oh let's go let's go
well we can make a level you wanna make
a level okay what is technology great
question you want to make sure we make a
level no I wanna say all right
oh yeah wait hold on let me go turn off
this music well no I mean we could do it
it's just gotta be annoying and you
can't hear our beautiful voices but I
think yeah yeah you're right yeah yeah I
was just no we don't care about network
features give me I just start how do I
start was boring you know I just let it
go let it go bro I'm starting part of
the game I'd like to start private game
here we go you're playing wait it's not
to Blair no why I don't know man can
they make it to Blair what here we go so
we're gonna we're gonna play a little
just why don't you learn the basics you
know you want to go up you want to go on
things new tricks oh my god far to be
the longest so far this is better than
my normal skin you nailed it nailed it
zero score zero still zero by the way
finishes
Asher Prague Chicago we are what a
beautiful road work when the holidays
are a little sloppy no split screen yet
hold don't tank of drones to attack the
driver that's high started real high on
that I did he started real high goddamn
basis with that but alright there we go
I'm gonna like tarjay play just a minute
minute oh my god you are really bad yeah
this is a really cool game that's right
that's right that's right you're just
killing it right now bro hey we're just
killing it hey guys where's the audience
Chewbacca's dance is another game that
chiropractors hate I love it chilly
processes this is the last stream the
year let's get that in on one of these
games that did talk about a while you
got hit the crotch with a magical fairy
and you fell down I don't
all right I'm gonna try something else
guys Alec 184 I think Star Wars is gonna
live up to the mighty need speed needs
to be need speed it is is done to the
hyper you think whoa grab Oh watch your
stance
are you
yeah I think I think start which is
definitely Oh nope no you're killing it
right now bro all right so after you
cool you got to hang on it you got that
yeah let's compete let's compete oh we
can compete yeah let's we're gonna
compete now like how do we do yeah Star
Wars gonna be awesome sorry's gonna be
great I'm really excited I'm for the
next like three days I need to just stay
off I agree I don't want to know any
spoilers wait how do I what if I can I
my levels clerk your levels how do we
fight each other can we do that there
might be that's a good question each
other all right let's do this we're
here's we're gonna do here we're gonna
do we're gonna play the barracks the
thing comes up and it just says load
here's what we're gonna do you ready
here we go take this okay now you're
gonna get a minute I'm at a time you're
gonna get a minute to do as many tricks
as you can okay all right
then we're gonna do a minute we're uh
let's see your hold on a second let me
go home it's my stopwatch here we go all
right now we're gonna play you ready
ready all right
you have zero zero right now no I
started with 275 all right fine we'll
give you a head start
yes I know how to play ready go ahead go
in a minute here we go
how did that not give me any points I
just broke a box with my skateboard can
see wow you're spending a lot of time on
the ground 47 seconds 40 for every
skater knows that's not enough time
never scared
I take wait this is exactly how they do
competitions by the way is it I think so
go how do I got 30 seconds wow you are
just wasting time
oh you're doing pretty good man you got
2600 all right 20 20 seconds come on
Tony's like if Tony had a stroke to do
that here we go 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
84 94 84 94 right here we go you take
this yeah
good luck beating that hold on wait no
wait wait wait wait wait go no I can't I
need to get out of here son
dude I get it the clock doesn't matter
you're in a clock doesn't lie
oh you're already 57 like better time
you're out the game's name boy guy are
you have 45 seconds all right here we go
so far almost hey nice trick wait what
did I have 20 you're like no way you're
lucky thousands at least somebody it's
hard to play these gloves on if we were
to go how do i unlock I don't know how
do you unlock there we go up seven five
four three two oh you already beat me
are you sure I didn't have 12,000 yeah
I'm pretty sure that taught that it's
over
guys wait I think it was like 86 it was
at 8 no you should I be you know that's
not true you owe me a coffee
that's ridiculous no I don't think so we
cancel out I think people are saying it
was in the 8000 it is not in the house
it had to have been an 8 that was no yes
I didn't do that me yeah I definitely
did more tricks today oh my god
yeah that's cuz I had to go back to the
maybe how many bars I was hiding to go
back that I had to go back to the menu
in eight thousand plus eight thousand
plus my nine for old [ __ ] watch it for
nine [ __ ] you guys are lying man
Justin 92 they are all saying different
or not without saying different things
he had yes like 2,600 no way spamming
crimes one I can't point a each and I
was doing so many ground oh my god you
ins grind is grind grind your own coffee
I'm about to go get a grind here no you
didn't I'm not paying for a grinder
yeah I want a grinder what did you get
me for Chris do you know the grinders I
don't know what a Graz sub sandwich
doesn't know yet but I'm not sure Beth
knows that's what's your favorite kind
of sandwich
I'm sorry Chewbacca's dad can't put
these gloves on I like a turkey okay you
like a turkey club so all right turn
clubs good there's a trick blood on any
mayonnaise ketchup sandwich spread
ketchup on it
I guess not ketchup Mustang that club
looks like I don't want to thank you
relish gumbo gumbo Beth is a loose
rattling candidate not a loose cannon is
in a rogue a loose cannon isn't like I
don't think this cannon is seeing drop
yeah yeah turkey for the win
that's abusing fess abusing her her
privileges oh yeah it says reply model
camera we're not playing Mortal Kombat
we're playing a bunch of different games
super loose the loosest of cannons hey
hey exactly Oh bet they have Ross but
these are calm down here it's getting
out of hand
cheese doughnuts and what the hell is
that
I like one a 2/4 I'm starving packs no
but we're going to some fat kick your
asses we're reckless and eggnog you want
to play back here I'll take this back
east
oh no that's not a good that teach how
to play you're asking me you see me just
play so I still don't know what makes
you do that
but I know that that one jumps X jumps
and then I think the triangle makes you
do that grinding thing plays in the chat
house look out man I love it down here
that's all I get good job back wow
that's cool you were like
that's the half pipe skills show tonight
somebody in the chat asking who's on the
show no one so any circus Oh Krysten
Ritter by the way is in Jessica Jones
right yep
she's in Breaking Bad have you guys seen
Breaking Bad no what's that your let's
go down translate to video game schools
oh god sighs pills there's an outside
correct
hey does everyone like me writing in all
caps Oh broke your leg
oh yeah oh man feds would be greater
than newsletter simulator trying to do
the garden oh my god all right it's time
to switch games you got a switch game
take this take this
time to go to the cave can we go to The
Witcher we do The Witcher let's do it
let's do it with your time well put us
you want to put us you wanna put us
full-strength
yeah wait your time Richard I'm not sure
which Witcher is Witcher you know now
you're sure to the church I have here's
a picture I have what about if we make a
game called the sandwich er yes I mean
you know and then Ryan darling you can
unlock a grinder we can unlock it Ryan
you have to go find the oven yeah then
you unlike the grinder
what would your character be in the
sandwich sandwich Irby a guy named chip
and I put chips on every sandwich oh wow
alright you said your your your special
mate would be it just like the chip at
the chipper the the chip attack the
salty chipper the BB q ER you know your
kettle chip man oh yeah all right kettle
chips oh yeah I hate salt and vinegar
chips I think I are disgusting I would
be more of a in the sandwich sure game I
would be more my name would be open face
and I would be like if you put gravy on
yeah yeah my I have a gravy gandhi-like
baby gun yeah that's the sound of make
yeah and so I would what I would do is
I'd be like a stealthy guy oh yeah I
would lay kettle chips on the ground
like cattle Jay mom listen okay and then
when somebody stepped away
good set kettle chip traps yes nice I
would have like gravy bombs I think like
ziploc bags full of gravy just like in
real life just like in real life
yeah exactly so and then what you're the
wild yeah yeah sandwich er the wild
Club there's a club so join the club
signature club sandwiches guys somebody
make that game how many streams we do
I wonder how many weeks how many weeks
are there near 52
we probably did 40 more than funny sick
sick huh yeah you're right now witcher 3
game of the year by the way so we played
this bad boy which were three games oh
this one game of the year i haven't
played this it's really funny here's the
prodigy 2016 projected gaming years
sandwich er oh yeah that's true
okay we got to rescale the hood here's
the problem with this is we haven't
actually played we played witcher on a
pc wow you can't see the image
regardless so we're gonna have to start
at the very beginning does this to Blair
no but you're gonna play it instead the
very beginning there's a lot of talking
you get it fully so I'm not sure how
much we're gonna get crew great why
don't we just skip this thing here's the
story that guy is a chicken baby
am ia chicken no you're not but that
would be and the sandwich or maybe you
have a friend who's a chicken well you
can do a special bonus pack or whatever
it's called where you can play a turkey
yeah and the sandwich you're chasing
that's a DLC right the DLC yeah you
don't want to get taken by the sandwich
or the sandwich er what the whole point
of the sandwich is just to take to find
ingredients for sandwiches you need to
go to like the queen of ham or a ham
queen to get the hand the hand cream and
you can take the subway to go between
worlds they call me and and yeah when
you do some special things for the ham
queen she slices off a piece of her and
gives it to you she's made of ham
exactly oh my gosh we can't skip this
exactly check it's got a deep voice it
exactly what is it guys good oh it's you
it's a child
yeah that's what our G looks like
without a beard how they get my
photograph baby faces ooh a nice little
watch there or C time you have to find
that ham bleacher
just saying you guys rocket League but
love rocket League what is that sounds
really cool rocket Lisa game with the
member we played soccer with cars oh
yeah yeah
but this we're playing we're trying to
get through all the games that we played
for close game does The Rocketeer have a
game no right you're probably did that
again should
look at this guy it's me without my
makeup exactly play against viewers we
will sometimes probably we have done
that before we will do it again
smoke tip 420 bet this game is dirty I
feel sorry for you and they are really
just laying it on thick with the story
we might only be able to watch the story
I mean I tried to hear you you want to
just hit me Raj you started out where
just slapping me laughing me in the face
this is how it started out that's right
just a slap that's right all right RJ RJ
says hurtful words which are more which
are more hurting than opponent's punches
like say say some hurtful words
oh my god Jesus oh hey that guy's take
that cut off oh my god
this is a long beginning this is gonna
be the entire time of the winter we play
the Rockets here NES game that blah blah
blah on to the SEC city I know
Christine banana but we can't I gotta
like Darth Vader and Skeletor yeah he
looks like Darth Skeletor finally a
reference that says who would win in a
fight between Darth Vader and and
what's-his-face Oh
Darth Vader and force amateur yes in the
sandwich area definitely who would make
a better sandwich Darth Vader here's the
sandwich we could skip this how the
buttons Doug Vader
here we go swear Oh new game finally
just the story watch this eight let's do
it Death March the sandwich sure would
make a better sandwich the Darth Vader
but I guarantee Darth Vader makes
we're doing death march oh my god now
they got it this is actually pretty cool
do you want to watch hope you skipped it
I didn't press anything do you want to
watch this or no just kidding
it's a pretty cool battle see terrible
hair is loosen up top don't want to skip
it skip it oh yeah all right we're gonna
say goodbye to our deck here that's
right passing of the sweaters right now
nice and sweaty get in here
hi everybody Merry Christmas gotcha
gotcha parting gift arrows hey bud
everyone please welcome really hurts
come in hi gang that's right he's very
warm
once again these sweaters provided by
tipsy elves go to tipsy elves calm
sweaters that's right that's right there
you go a [ __ ] Jewish you're gonna love
this Christmas sweater fireman so we're
watching this fine Nick Cage simply safe
that's right we're watching we're
watching The Witcher here very exciting
tired you get only healing up the
sweater how flock oh they got the
sweater have fun you can just keep it a
half on
now you know what on that note let me
ask you a question we came up with our
own game called The Witch of the
sandwich er and now in the sandwich er I
would be my name would be open-faced and
I would have a gravy gun slash gravy
bombs
what would your sandwich our character
be without you Joe oh god you Joe and
what's focaccia Joe is as special
doesn't take the glasses off by the way
but gotcha Jose what's focaccia Joe's
big deal with what he loves fresh bread
and has very little time for like
[ __ ] condiments yeah so what but how
does he fight what's his special moves
oh I thought I just ate a lot I mean you
do that's part of the sick glory of
Samuraizer Joe spicy and aggressive okay
and okay he tried to be a horrible it's
just soft bread yeah maybe he's got me
baby he's got piccata first right
we chose like nerve yeah like a
sparring-partner okay but terrible okay
that's fine I'm fine with it alright
great
and now we're almost done 20 minutes
later almost over which really this by
the way won Game of the Year awesome
game Ward's I own oh great well you
should play this ten years do you hate
it every single game I've load you yeah
let's go over the portal to one of my
favorite games portal 2 I'll enter oe
out hates it I liked for like 20 minutes
and then a Skyrim you hate it yeah
couldn't even I think you put even fired
it up once
yeah was another game Oh Batman
Oh Batman Arkham Knight hated Batman
Arkham Knight why did you hate Batman
Arkham Knight I don't anything with too
much possibilities and too much detail
is not for me Annie
I like linear so I'm like a child I need
like a boiled down linear like hey
here's your one there's only one
omission you can do yeah this is not an
open sandbox there's one which is why I
gave you portal 2 which you immediately
hated yeah but that was like puzzles how
can you hate portal 2 let me just goes
what
yeah exactly I would
Christine banana asks what games do you
like I like I would love to hear this
well right now I'm playing the
battlefront the Star Wars Battlefront
are you liking it I am I am like wow big
effing nerd but what I really like is
like Call of Duty or even halo where
it's like first-person shooter simple
here's some missions you can campaign
before we gonna have and then spend the
better part of a year like playing live
online and being destroyed by
nine-year-old got it
like first-person shooter super simple
not going online you know and then I'll
do your online online multiplayer get
killed okay yeah so like Call of Duty
that kind of stuff so it means that a
bluesman says you need to play Uncharted
you should play Uncharted it's kind of
like guy thank you he'll hate it
he'll hate it cuz there's riot okay it's
not really first-person shooter though
who look at this look at it that's
that's of bad acne oh you just caused
three could be fun no no vercelli
vercetti there's too much possibility in
Just Cause 3 yeah I'm you Lucius 861 he
likes battlefront pack it up boys
well yeah wait Jubilee you know you
should get away you that's I don't I
just got a PS she knows crazy psycho GTA
5 he hates GTA 5 like it's super fun to
drive around and get into trouble but
that's look at your bike look at the
sacks of Russians does not work well for
me Slayer Dart
Zach's got strips of bacon on his back
it strips of bacon what scars
oh yes strips all you see is food you
would love the sandwich er here you take
this here to play look at that baby
whoa that's right a blue isthmus always
suggests I charted I like it oblivious
miss when you speak of yourself in the
third person I'm gonna burn up in this
thing and not because those are stretch
marks
it used to be 500 pounds exactly give me
that booty too much nudity here we go Oh
what we dressed rather quickly what is
what is your opinion by the way on giant
necklaces do you like giant necklaces
you are so Mauro I'm a chili cheese dog
I used to wear a lot of like hemp
necklaces with like back in the day how
do we let you on the stream the dreads
don't FAP it's a trap since Kelly
all right Walker out here let's look at
some stuff alright let's do some doing
alright so if you hold l2 you can do
your Witcher sense they'll tell you kind
of what - alright so you see you can
look at that cup okay yeah you got the
meat sweats as pretty exactly you're
right
wait vide Hawks is like Flavor Flav's
necklaces like a modest flava flav dubs
of nugs we're playing all the games
we're trying to get through all the
games we did for clueless gamer this
year and rocket league was not one of
them unfortunately the wheel play rocket
League in the new year
so some sparkly boozy you want to go
over to the where the yellow is you want
to go over to where the yellow oh this
joint yeah the door okay
Slayer dogs just play with your favorite
Christmas metal band mine Slayer well
done
ah mine would be oh you got to get a key
you got it whoo use your winter senses
to find the key oh look at that
sparkling sparkling
ah my favorite let's all come up with
anything try to get through a day where
there's lifestyle
look also on the map you see on the map
up there go into where the thing is this
is this Susan this is why I like a thing
where they're like ticket hey there's a
guy in that building you have to kill
him you can snipe and more creep up
behind him in the shadows great that I
can handle but this oh I need a key look
at a man ha ha ha somebody ask favorite
ah let's see
death metal Christmas band I like
okay somebody's gonna freak death can
you name more than one name a death
metal band
how about man I don't want it I want to
come up why out let's see what about
what's a good metal man I don't know any
definite
imos antara Jake Jake 8a said that's
good
how much did you go home at night and
lock yourself out yeah that's no no
that's yennefer just talk to her there
okay Oh Lamb of God is pretty good shady
fish that's a real hey Matty estar hello
Poland look for elves tattoos on this
airline of like Frankenstein who does we
got from Wayne Oh God dudes are intense
Wow but super cool what's this matter
now just watch this is soap opera unfold
look Dan Rather again hey Albert Jacques
what's up and somebody's just tell me
where the keys so I can do I don't know
where the keys we're gonna all right I'm
late
you got a fine I think you got to go to
the center there buddy up there I think
you want to turn to the right and go you
term up this thing yeah is it someone
over here ignite I did I just
extinguished no okay I'm really good at
making fires I'm not exactly sure
jump can I go up on top of there I'm
sorry I can't IDs WP cz I love it love
this game no he is not doing well in
this game but that's okay
yeah oh Insane Clown Posse has a
Christmas album whoa
do I have the key what's the one I
didn't even know I had the kid good job
you gotta get out of this room bro he
got out of the room guys thanks for
letting me play guys I love it I think
he was literally the first thing you
picked up and played like you're wrong
oh yes you don't right listen to me yes
what wafer this Israelis first time
playing Witcher in my second this is my
first time playing anything on the desk
for that's not Jesus Christ committed to
the cause I love it I love it
my kids love watching me play
battlefront but that became real awkward
uh-huh when like my daughter's like dad
choke him
tether choking oh my god and my son was
like yeah kill it I was like I do
speeder bikes now all they want is me
Darth Vader and dudes all kind of things
so they're more for the Empire though
really more fascinated by very appealing
right they're intrigued yes like this
thing right like that and then you curl
people it's very funny
all right we've done enough winter now
we got it we're running out of time we
got a switch we're gonna switch to fall
out we're gonna search oh another game
will be horrible right we're gonna
switch to fall so
here's the thing I actually have been
playing a lot of Falls so we're just
gonna switch to my again because we have
a lot of weapons and I think this is I
think I'm gonna get you the like ball
out I guess it'll be a lot of death your
into death I'm okay with that
you're fine with that can we switch to
fall out yeah like a nuclear fallout uh
yeah this is where we just watch the
clueless gamer that we did that bodies
right explain to people what you do on
the ship I deal with the music the guest
bands that play on the show and and
occasionally I've seen players videos
I've worn one costume and it was blue
Irish means you're lying I wore yeah so
I deal with the bands that play on the
show yes I'm on the Conan show that's
right sweating so here's what you could
take you want to take the sweater look
take the sweater off fine bro if someone
had asked how you got into your position
if you would if you were to answer that
Jen I have rude to ask
no thank you Thank You Alec 182 for it
was a fun one to do I'm sorry I deserve
it's okay no it's that's better walking
I filled in for the person that had my
job before me I've been working here for
15 years
there we go and and yeah and so that's
how I came to do that I'd filled in a
couple times and and then just took over
in music like what are your favorite
kinds of musical guests to watch in
person favorite kind favorite kinds on
our show to watch what we just had a
great singer on like you can't ignore
the power of a great singer yeah like me
Lukas Graham like you like me I've a
beautiful I'm great rapper this guy
Lukas Graham who I wasn't familiar with
that Jimmy our Booker book yeah and he
could just sing like crazy and
unbelievably good like an audience and
it wasn't super familiar with him before
was very very impressed
my favorite like professionally speaking
he's
country acts not because I'm a literally
a huge fan of that genre but it is
without a doubt like the most organized
easy-like days I can ever have some some
artists are a little more it's a little
more you have to negotiate a little bit
more yeah yeah sure reduction
difficulties and this and that and you
know when a country actors come and plug
this into the one we're gonna use
everything's gonna show up on time and
and ready to work and it will be exactly
what they told you would be a month
prior I love that is what comes in in
the morning it was interesting when we
back at the Tonight Show
we interviewed a lot we I can't remember
what we did we did some kind of
interviewee thing we do a lot of behind
the scenes stuff obviously and it always
amazed me country acts like since they
do like such a specific type of radio
show and stuff they have their stuff
together like Lady Antebellum yes like
they have like a thing of like so lady
I'm and about was kind of three is like
three main people and they're like I I'm
sorry I don't know their names but it's
like I'm Joe I'm Harry and I'm you know
whatever like Tanisha and we're Lady
Antebellum you know and they have like a
thing they know how to have had to give
you a sound yeah yeah and it was easy
because kind of the only other the only
other person that that kind of happened
with me was pitbull pitbull is the same
way and it was great because because
he's awesome smells great body but he
got he's like he's like hey look we're
wide 585 people you know you're just
like wow like you are on it dude I love
it
that was like amazing so like I remember
we did our med thing on the stage next
door hey Hawks easy hello Czech Republic
summer summer conan music or something
like the first year we got here we ended
with pitbull yeah and literally we had
like fans on all week and we ended with
pitbull and he almost broke just it like
there was so much energy and the
audience was people were like vibrating
yeah and it was broke televisions oh my
god it was it was unbelievable that was
so fun who's just like medleys of crazy
crazy
at least of crazy hits Conan was dancing
yeah that was awesome
slurred are says quick question for you
and Roy it's actually row II like Joey
we get coded to interview any guest
living or dead who would it be himself
how about coda to interview himself
because it's really interesting I think
when talk show hosts are interviewed by
other talk show hosts because you get to
see their varying styles and also it's
funny for Conan to not he's only kind of
been on a a handful of other shows but
it's always fun to watch him not be in
control right because he always so
drives the conversation so it's
interesting when he does enjoyed the
conversation and I think I'd like to see
him try to I try to fight over himself
I'll take one step for like him on
Howard Stern oh great hello digital
cowboy I didn't it was terrific
partially because rooted yeah yeah I
mean it was like an hour and change long
so you've got a lot out of him I'd like
to see the flip of that yeah absolutely
all right here's how you play this game
ready this is the wasteland okay
this is our home base that we've got
some power over here let's just put
we're gonna put on some car armor
because it'll be more fun for you all
right
down the lower right oh yeah I know
actually you can keep us up there that's
good sorry right there yeah I think it's
okay or up you know upper right might be
better I think all right so we've got a
big power armor this is us we're gonna
walk around we're gonna go now we're
just gonna wander the wasteland we're
gonna go down over here and we're gonna
just try to murder some stuff anything
about that sounds like something I can
handle
so just shoot things yeah you know what
though here's the other thing I'm gonna
do I'm gonna get you some whoa all right
this all this is this game I don't need
this just me this game is this game
isola high no I'm gonna give you a gun
that's called this spray and spray it
dude these are all amazing and you like
three what happen to the spray Oh God
okay oh man that's your hot dog is
sitting real good all right let's go
we're gonna go down it's gonna be great
all right no all the Potter is gonna
walk around in this murder thing now
here's the deal here's the deal
right trigger shoots got it okay if
there's a bad guy you can hit the left
bumper and it'll slow down time and you
can pick what you want to shoot bullet
time bullet time now we're speaking each
other's language
it's amazing you can't handle all the
possibilities no I need that it's way
too dark here I want a flashlight he's
really dark right let's see where I'm
going okay you know what let's do this
then let's do this oh this right let it
go just let it go
I've already ruined the game no no it's
fine we're just gonna sit down you can
do a thing ready to sit down and read a
book yeah you can sit down and wait is
there a chair in here you got to do it
in a chair
you'd sit wait for daylight yeah can I
sit here
wait yeah hold on
instead what we're gonna do instead
you're going to change the team you just
walk around
I can just go south I'll just make it
work look just go south go south see on
your compass on the bottom that goes
south yeah a left trigger will get you
your scope going okay yeah how's my
bullet time there's my trigger might be
and I run out of run yeah you can play
it you plan this plan this event you I'm
changing the thing on here let's see if
I shoot I give myself away yeah this
thing read read read business that's a
car how's that a little better
yes am I still heading style we have
lots it oh there's no ammo for the
sniper gun whoops let's switch that
sorry
so proud
all right now we have a shotgun yay that
gives people that does ten points of
poison damage she also got a poison
people pass
yeah all right yeah here's the thing kid
turbo I don't like using the pip-boy
light because I don't like using
flashlights to general video game
because it draws attention to yourself
we can put the light on if you want but
see I hate the light it just makes you a
target
so who's the noob now my take you can
take Roy to the Swan week I killed the
swamp
I feel animals are my looking for dudes
oh you can kill animals if you want I
mean I wouldn't but you know cuz I'm a
nice guy well oh by the way our
companion codsworth hates those animals
so Oh triangle jumps but thank you
okay the smuggler just scheduled their
wisdom tooth surgery for the 29th you're
ringing in the New Year by pulling bones
out of here let's go oh I'm in Armour
sorry I'm in armor so it's a headlamp
that's cool huh huh huh oh wait wait go
to the go to the oh yeah you can go
straight wait go back there yeah we're
gonna discover something which will be
cool actually you know what here let's
do this just do this for a second I'm
gonna give you some cool I think do we
have the this is a pro yeah let's do the
ZipZap you want the ZipZap
sure are you about the spray-and-pray I
like that too let's see this ZipZap the
same trigger yeah same same stuff this
is just a laser gun
well kill that thing kill it shooting
I'm shooting a bunch it's a laser to
matter I'm gonna you can also you don't
have to hit left or you just hit right
trigger and kind of shoot from the hip
you can hold the right right bumper and
I have to do this to throw grenade but
oh that's left bumper ok so now you can
hit the trigger and then if you hit X
it'll do the slow-motion shot all right
now you just keep firing on please
you're on a lot of AP points you just
gotta shoot from the hip man you just
gotta shoot from the hip
you're preheating that baricza whoo look
at showing us its bottom shoot now just
keep junik keep shooting it shoot it not
the sky that's another one really that's
another one dude we're oh you got a
contract got him Cogsworth
alright now you can loot the body if you
want you can go over to the body I'll
loot the bear carcass
yeah the bear carcass and get some yokai
meat yo yeah yeah yeah xx
it's a bear it's a time you do I need
more from the rest of ya that's fine
it's fun though I'm taking the bear hug
Wow yeah you go over to the right go
over to the right and we discover some
other stuff we go wait wait I think
there's something else that's radiation
you don't want to get near that what's
good old fashioned yah guy BBQ contra
this good for something I like concert
there's a companion my leg is hey yeah
go ahead
oh that's it's okay it's your armors
feel like goat straight see what that is
over there yeah
that's a mine we don't care alright
coming easy dude
come in hot this place was there's bad
guys in here
well I have this very efficient laser
gun my ZipZap
just stick your hand in there so it's
not about the bottom I don't think
there's anybody in here oh oh turn
around turn around oh my god oh there's
mole rats inside oh there's got to be a
better yeah you can do the left bumper
man thinking near you you can do the
left bumper you know alright oh it's a
glowing mole rat oh you know what
somebody said yo guy he's like Yogi Bear
it's like a joke oh that's awesome
I love that I'm just like cosworth hoo
hoo weasal all around the radiation how
nice feel free to try to kill stuff oh
Hancock's your favorite companion I
should go get oh yah guy is like a demon
in Chinese oh that's good to know dude
are you saying Yogi Bear is it is
actually a demon interesting oh yeah you
slicing that guy up
remove God's white egg cat voice hey Oh
legendary glowing mole rat let's kill
that mole rat and then the ghost search
the body
I left bumper well you seen my wife
foreign aid
hey go over there search the body so we
can we can see what it did well what
it's got it got something legendary go
down there yeah whoo take that Thanks
what get so your ex don't you / yes hole
press and hold ax get back in your
frickin suit hey Bob Jesus
we're like naked be aware of boo-boos as
we go here we go I wanted to air it out
dad it is kind of fun yeah yeah just
take the pistol there you go take it
there we go all right get out of here
hey speck aspect to your 74 hello Czech
Republic I don't have Czech Republic
what do you call them Batman skips
Church I don't know so go down let's
let's discover that thing go south go
south
walk around what do you call it in
Batman skips Church I don't know now you
guys are starting to see why I like a
simple game you're doing all right good
man you killed a bunch of old rats there
you go all right there we go oh my god
how I go oh yeah you can keep going
straight so you want to kind of go see
it on the bottom there you see the
compass out the stuff that's just
outlines like the stuff on the so you
can go either to the right or to the
left seat that that weird factory thing
yeah no not the white thing but to the
left of it yeah I go that way there we
go yeah cuz then we'll discover that
stuff heck is this XP hey JT JK teh oh
my god somebody got six inches of snow
today boo-boos not avoidable if the
naturalist all that for all the picnic
basket
yeah man a lot of Czech Republic today
in the chat I like it did you check it
out sorry I had to do it what's this
what about warehouse yeah let's get in
there
so my giant laser gun this is yeah yeah
it's going that let's go in there so you
can get in there Holly square
I feel like college square is gonna be
very hard for us C+ you're scared
oh let's go in that door I just saw my
god hey probably cuz there's something
in there but let's go in the door
alright look in there's hoots in there a
new peekaboo anybody home
that's get in there get it on to her
door to do uh unlock it can't oh this is
gonna be great alright so we're gonna
pick this lock you want to turn to the
left a light stick you slowly wanna you
hate this the right stick you position
the bobby pin okay the left stick you
slowly turn okay if it starts jiggling
you got to stop cuz then the bobby pin
will break let it go let go I let go all
right yeah they pick another spot for
the body on you're trying to get as far
as you can to the right the thing
turning without the bobby pin like
rattling does that make sense
okay so pick another spot with bobby pin
oh wow well done he didn't even move the
bobby pin yeah how do you like me now
so you can look around here and loot
something there you know it always
Stevie to sit in the chair so you can
sit in the chair turn around turn on I'm
looking gonna no no no no your that go
it set on that couch you sit please
Jesus sit X oh my god thing alright get
out of the power armor sorry hold ax
what was that I just that wasn't you
that [ __ ] him
I held X hold ax just hold X all right
now turn around and get point at the
couch great sit sit
oh my god went combat now ah get back in
the power armor hold on I'm just gonna
kill these guys do this are you know you
pull out your gun right trigger right
all right my gun out no they're not and
this is the gun we want me to use sure
go for it yeah yeah we have a lot of
bullets Oh God all right great let's get
out there just murderer you know the
other thing we're gonna do like that so
how do I use that you're in a hole hold
right bumper don't do it in here don't
do it in here
you guys it's a lot of cocktail what is
that I don't know exactly that looks
like a feral ghoul to me Oh thorough
cool yeah you know what those girl
ghouls pulses around here Wow oh thank
sure that's your bad guy yeah yep do i
oh yeah kill him oh he's eating somebody
oh nice Linna ma i like to zoom who's
that I think that's great
no Burton in SA there's our there's a
guy are the guys coming over here and do
I get like a Kirk headshots accuracy
yeah I mean if you can hit it oh wow
shut his arm off well done pop that you
pop that dude oh wow I'm here I'm buddy
close there's a lot of people you might
want to you might want a left love break
you might want a left well Chris oh man
well done I don't know how do I
how come I can't shoot you just you
gotta hit axe you've used all your
points
there you go oh you'll have another
point yeah yeah Oh God yep yep yep yep
yep yep shoot it shoot him
oh god oh Jesus oh geez I'm gonna reload
now I know rocket punch you were the
feral ghoul because he's possessed with
the will to eat flesh
well starving behind you behind you
ideas you've told me about earlier
I mean it's I'm figuring if he saw him
literally eating a dead body you would
think that that would be something wait
no wait go uh hey kill mom well done
well I mean oh no we know you did
there's somebody else how do you know
where because there's a red dot on your
map you can't see because they can't
read I don't know where he is though is
he up do you want to look up oh there is
there is sorry oh wow cows would cut his
head off
how great is cosmic he's in it I keep I
need to shoot him I don't know yeah it's
okay you can't hurt it oh if you do he
always he you can't you can't kill him I
love you
whoa hey yep yep yep
there we go right in the knees that's
what I oh wow yeah I dude you are
intense abyss alright no go straight go
straight and let's see if we can get
yeah yeah go straight and let's go to a
police station keep going straight to
the right
there we go baby oh yeah
oh yeah going there killing there yep
going let's go to the shooting
are there other humans you know you know
I do let's switch away let's switch to a
cooler gun it's gonna be fun it's gonna
be a fun one I love this gun now this is
a tommy gun with exploitable bullets oh
you're gonna love this gun let's get in
there let's get in there let's help this
guy out shoot all the feral ghouls
pop-pop-pop them nice nice yep yep yeah
that's a good guy alright let's get in
there it's helping out hey what's up bro
turn around turn around turn around here
they come here they come
Tommy the bad guys there we go there we
go oh yeah you light them up Cogsworth
get out of the way nothing is constantly
trying to take plenty video I could not
survive oh yeah oh boy sounds kinky
Dopson I'm the wasteland well done let's
not speak palliative dance let's get out
of here I don't want to type this guy
we're gonna start a whole mission if
we'd have to talk to this guy out now
yeah go back out let's discover more
buildings go yet go straight who else is
in College square we should talk to you
if I talk I mean shoot the face what's
this is this we're second I was like
which buttons me see vision of the other
game yeah wait let's get out of here so
you can go around this building
hellooo peekaboo oh yeah get down in
here hey I love this game because it's
like every time there's a light it's
always dead like lights equal death in
this game especially at night it's like
oh come over here this is safe cut to
you just pure death hey everybody it's
down here Oh oh yeah oh let's get in
there or just throw them all talk talk
yeah do it do it how about a little fire
scarecrow oh you might like get a little
down in there whip it down and dance it
boss oh it's quite nice oh man
killed it what was that thing I don't
know exactly like an armadillo
that's a mirelurk all right dad let's
see what else is going on the Marlette
go back down in there yeah I would oh
yeah you want to sweep it out they're
not just gonna kill themselves oh
there's nothing else in there so one man
sweep to one man sweet one-man army
so does activate for a first time run
row he's doing pretty good yeah thank
you I think those nuka-cola
could take him Jerry yeah oh yeah I tell
ya they're delicious so like a limit to
how much stuff I can carry there is but
we're in power of our Soviet doesn't
most senior carries more yeah yeah I'm
asking like practical but now you're
doing great man
all right there's killing see is this a
fun game let's shred it
whatever that let's try to those two
buildings we've got you guys go up out
of this let's try to discover those two
building discovering places I'm really
into this game because it gets you
experience points without really having
to do much other than walk around oh
wait is that a bad guy on the right
family don't you see something wait go
straight oh no those are legend sorry
but yeah straight ahead as a pharmacy
let's go over there try go
there we go I take a phone call I need
to make a call oh wait oh no you can't
go in that door go inside or something I
don't see how this could end poorly I'm
hearing something nice nice
well there's a graveyard there we are
using fast but Royal just likes to take
matters into his own hands let's go to
that graveyard see if there's any other
bad guys I have a personal what's up
back fat is the valta type of Auld
assisted targeting system which is what
it time slows down oh yeah I just like
to like head straight showed me how to
do that right oh yeah we might have
killed all the ghouls in this graveyard
I think they all just ran out at us it's
pretty easy is it great though how this
gun just like players exploding bullets
yeah let's go to the lat let's go either
straight up to the left see we can get
more dangerous buildings here oh wait
what's this in there I think I've
already killed all those people
but see what's you want me to go down
here uh yeah I just said go that made me
go the other way let's go the other way
we're just cleaning out college square
man I love this yeah go straight go
straight this way straight no no the
other mystery this yeah go that man see
how do you not like these games because
it's just this like I can wander around
hours you get obsessed at the that's
when I do it as we talked about like
every you could ask that has a cabinet
with roars I know well I have to check
every drawer on every cabinet in every
room and check every armoire that's
exactly how I get so you can't go in
there those doors
I just keep going straight till we
discover that thing straight over we're
going towards that outlet oh yeah Oh
let's get down Oh kill that glowing guy
I hate those freaking things this guy
yeah kill him
Oh future he's so cute oh my people oh
man now I got her might be above our
level but we can do it that's it that's
it that's it
oh Jesus oh you know what let's switch
to the nuclear bomb oh wait here hey hit
X to accept
now let's nuke it Obama let's nuke to
the bottom hold on oh yeah all right
here we go
just shoot him with this rather shoot
him with that wherever he is nobody step
a little bit away though oh god this is
not I don't know well I don't know I
don't know where they are
don't do it when you're close though
don't do when you're close oh geez oh
geez you okay okay wait wait let's get
back here here I'll get a shotgun here
we go go hit him with the shotgun pop
him pop him yep yep yep yep oh yeah oh
yeah nice job oh my god you're freaking
legs are about to here we go oh yeah
that's great to him I mean kind of I
wouldn't do hit him too close yeah oh
god geez now you're in the thing okay
now you're fine
oh my god it didn't kill him it didn't
kill him hit him again
hit him again hit him again yeah
nice well done well done well done drew
we hear that what sweet haunts all right
let's do this money the whole the game
is all is all this basically alright
nice job let's loot the body
I love looting poop putrid thing oh wow
you're down in the [ __ ] now there
anything down here I wonder as long as
we can kill everybody oh that guy right
nice loot him up ah
HP versed he said never played a
previous fall before it's poor related
story no not really
you can just pick up fallout 4 it's not
really related hey Todd etx good to see
those ghouls are not from the Czech
Republic what's he gonna do a lot of
legs he's not gonna do really anything
about his legs because high ground yeah
up the stairs see what's up let's tear
this guy's pro skills hey there you go
you can just walk through the thing and
out if you count the characters yeah
they take place in the same universe
about ten years away from each other oh
there you go
ah there you go well done yeah walks
walk straight let's go through here the
spray-and-pray it's the tommy gun with
the exploding bullets alright I do love
that gun alright also it's got a nice
little silencer on it so it just like
doesn't really get away a lot of your
position yeah this way sure either way
oh go that's nice it's down here you are
very you are very scattered in this game
you I that's why I'm like I'm always I
imagine everything that's been placed
has been deliberately placed so well
that's true
so when I see yeah it's yeah keep going
Jesus you're so jumpy just walk straight
you spend like half your time spinning
around rowing in the world is just like
walk yeah what is this oh it's a mire
like light him up light him up can I hit
him with yeah hit him let him with us
yeah yeah Adam Aaron little bit yeah
light him up dude dude you gotta get on
my way nice well done
I also like wow first apart one of my
favorite things is like you get this
chi-ching every time you kill somebody
which is like a weird Pavlovian response
and kill them
Enclave I don't know if the Yacht Club
makes it appearance to this game I
haven't really been playing the story
I've just been walking around murdering
everyone just real fun oh my god you
can't figure out a way together
I love this that's blocked by a camera
so I don't I'm assuming that's what's
supposed to tell me where I'm supposed
to go cheers ESCO beats what's up the
sweater is real hot yeah sure
nice little scenic walk
yeah scenic stroll along the waterfront
sure nothing bad lives near the
waterfront we done died well you know
what actually it's about time for I'll
kill these guys come on oh yeah I think
we look cute let's turn on the left
bumper left bumper
you
thank you guys for joining us the last
Monday Man of the Year Happy Holidays
and we will we'll see you guys next year
and ro you want to say anything
thanks for letting me play see you the
next one oh don't see on battlefront si
UN battlefront alright see you guys
later
and I'll be streaming on twitch.tv slash
Aaron blare later in the week if you
want to play more stupid games and send
me more game recommend days that's right
and next year I'm a my new year's
resolution is to get Beth to play more
video games
who's with me hashtag more game Beth
more games
she's the bet bye guys happy holidays
see you guys later bye beer look at this
dumb sweater
you